- With regard to General
Flynn and his unmasking,
I think it goes at least up to Joe Biden.
Joe Biden, we now have documents
that were declassified yesterday
by Ric Grenell that show
that Joe Biden requested the
unmasking of General Flynn.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and
this is The Rubin Report.
Quick reminder everybody
to subscribe to our channel
and click that little bell so
so you get delivered our videos.
And more importantly,
joining me today is the
junior senator from Kentucky
and the fiercest defender of liberty
that we have in the
United States government.
Senator Rand Paul, I'm thrilled
you're finally joining us.
- I'm glad to Dave,
glad to be on your show.
- All right, so let's dive in.
I think we're just gonna
split this interview,
I know you've got about a half hour.
We're gonna just split it into two parts.
Let's spend the first half talking about
this FISA Amendment
that you just proposed.
Can you just talk a little
bit about why you did it,
what's going on with surveillance?
I sense people are seriously confused
about the whole Flynn case,
what the Obama administration
may or may not have known.
So if you could just kinda do a 101
to clean up some of that,
that would be great.
- Well the FISA Court is the
Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Court,
and it was set up in the '70s basically to
investigate, spy on, surveil
foreigners and possible terrorists.
It was never intended for it to be used
against political candidates,
or to investigate American
political campaigns
or American political figures.
But as everybody knows,
this is what the secret
court that they used
to go after President Trump in 2016
in the summer and the fall.
And,
I think this was a horrendous
abuse of power and,
using a secret court
to go after an American
I think is a travesty of justice.
So this is a court that lacks
constitutional protections.
When you go to a regular court,
a constitutional court
that was established
by Article III of the Constitution,
you get a lawyer,
that's one obvious thing you get.
But you also get the Fourth Amendment.
The Fourth Amendment says that
they can't search your house,
or your phone, or any of these things
unless they go to a judge
and they have to say that
there's probable cause
that you committed a crime.
It's a fairly high standard,
but it's the constitutional standard.
In the FISA Court, they
go do it and they say,
well, you just have to have probable calls
that we think you are associated
with a foreign government.
So that's what they did with Carter Page.
They said, "Oh, we see
you talk to the Russians."
And he said,
"Well, yeah I told the CIA.
"I've run into Russians, I do business,
"I'm in these think tanks.
"And I told the CIA,
"and they know that I've
talked to the Russians before
"and I've tried to give them information."
They discounted all of
that, lied to the FISA Court
and then, what began this
whole Trump investigation.
But here's my point.
A lot of Republicans,
a lot of conservatives,
lot of Libertarians who are upset.
How do you fix it?
One way of doing it is to try
to make the FISA Court system
more like a constitutional court.
So add protections, in
the scheme of things.
But here's my point.
I don't think it's possible
to make it constitutional.
They don't notify you that
they're investigating you,
so it's secret.
You don't get a lawyer.
Some of the reforms are to
give you a friend, an amicus,
so somebody a friend of the court,
that argues for you but
they still don't tell you
you've been accused of anything,
so you don't really direct a
lawyer to direct your defense.
And so, I don't think it fixes the system.
So my amendment would simply say this,
the FISA Court really isn't
constitutional for Americans
so let's exempt Americans from it,
and let's use it only on foreigners.
It is, for all,
it's called the Foreign
Intelligence Court.
Why don't we go after foreigners with it?
And people say, well,
what if there really was a
spy in a political campaign?
What would you do?
Well, use the Constitution, go to a judge,
ask for a warrant to search the person
or to surveil the person.
And judges do grant things like that,
but you have to evidence.
But you'd also have to
obey the Bill of Rights
and the Fourth Amendment.
That's what I'm for but unfortunately,
I'm in the minority up here.
I think that would win
with your crowd watching,
(Dave laughs)
but I'm afraid it probably,
it didn't have enough
votes in the Senate to win.
- Yeah, well I assure you
you're doing just fine
and the majority on my audience and
we've got some work to do there.
So can you just clarify a little bit?
It seemed that sort of
right leaning Twitter,
let's call it right now is saying,
that this stuff really went
up the chain of command,
and it's possible now that
Biden and/or Obama themselves
actually knew about it
and we're instigating some of this stuff.
What's the actual evidence at this point?
- Well, with regard to General
Flynn and his unmasking,
I think it goes at least up to Joe Biden.
Joe Biden, we now have documents
that were declassified yesterday
by Ric Grenell that show
that Joe Biden requested the
unmasking of General Flynn.
What does that mean?
They get like a national
security or a FISA warrant
to listen to the phone call
of the Russian ambassador.
I can kind of understand that.
We spy on ambassadors, they spy on us.
That goes on all around the world.
But if that ambassador is talking to a
person who's elected to our government,
or part of the administration
like General Flynn,
they're supposed to say,
oh, no he's talking to an American,
we're not supposed to listen.
Or if we listen,
we're not supposed to unmask that person.
Well, the thing is if
you're a prominent person,
a lot of people know you by your voice
and you may well introduce
yourself by saying,
Mr. Ambassador this is General Flynn.
So it's kind of,
- [Dave] Sure.
- it's hard to really completely mask it.
But here's the point.
You're only supposed to unmask that person
if there's national security reasons.
So if they're plotting to attack the U.S,
you'd say well, that's reasonable.
You'd unmask them and
try to stop the plot.
But if they're discussing policy,
and the person is the
National Security Advisor,
there would be absolutely no reason,
other than a politically motivated one.
So if this is politically motivated,
then it becomes illegal
surveillance, illegal eavesdropping.
And really, you remember we
had this impeachment trial
over them saying someone in government
used government to go
after a political opponent.
Turns out, what they did to General Flynn
sounds exactly like that they abused
- [Dave] Yeah.
- government,
they used surveillance to go
after their political opponent.
- Are you worried, for
a limited government guy
you don't want the administrative
state to be too big,
it's like you can get in the
weeds on all of this stuff
but in many ways,
this is what you've spent
your whole life fighting,
that the whole system
has just gotten so big
and crazy at this point,
that even if you tell people what's true,
and we have all the facts in front of us
that sort of, the ship has sailed
on reining in the things
that I think you and I
and most of my audience are worried about.
- Yes and no.
I think if you would ask
your audience, obviously,
it's probably a very
limited government audience.
But even if you ask a general audience.
So for example, if I ask
everybody in Kentucky
about whether or not a secret court
where you don't get a lawyer
should investigate political campaigns,
I would say oppose it 75%,
particularly if you keep Trump out of it.
Now Trump's pretty popular in my state
so it doesn't hurt so much,
but really if you could
get Trump out of it.
But the problem is,
people get that they won't
vote on principle and ideas so
I didn't get any Democratic votes on this.
I only got 11 Republicans,
but I got no Democrats.
Even though many of them profess to
think that FISA has too much power
and shouldn't be investigating Americans,
they wouldn't vote for it
cause they saw it as a vote
rebuking FISA over Trump.
And so they saw it as a political vote.
But I guess I don't look at it this way.
I lose a lot of times.
I'm used to losing on votes in the Senate.
(Dave laughs)
But I think most of this,
and this is where we do have some ability
so we pass out a sheet of prominent tweets
that went out from senators
each week on Wednesday.
And our office does this sheet.
And they all complain because
we'll put out something
and my tweet will have
gotten 30,000 retweets
and then we'll put out Senator so-and-so,
and they got six.
(Dave laughs)
- So, right,
one of the things they see is that
the Liberty Movement has
reached well beyond them
and they fear the election.
These people are afraid of elections,
they're afraid of me,
they're afraid of conservatives
cause they're afraid someday
someone's gonna wake up
and challenge them in the primary.
And that's what has to happen.
The Democrats, it's sort of like this.
Democrats don't care at
all about the deficit
and they'll tell you.
They wanna spend more money,
they're honest about it.
Republicans,
well, say they're against debt,
say they're against
spending but they're also,
most of them, big government Republicans,
vote lockstep with the Democrats.
So really, when people
ask me whose fault is it,
Republican or Democrat?
I say yeah, it is really
both party's fault.
But, we could give up,
and just try to protect ourselves,
but, I think if we give up
and the few good voices here go away,
then really I think it goes
much quicker toward Socialism,
it goes much quicker towards
indebtedness and big government
so there has to be some voices.
There needs to be more.
The newer people up here I
think are frankly better than,
the ones that have been here a long time.
So I have good conversations
with Senator Braun,
Senator Rick Scott from Florida,
and who I think are open to (mumbles)
to vote with me on my FISA Amendment.
Mike Lee, who is with me
on the FISA Amendment also.
- Can you talk a little bit about
your relationship with Trump?
Because one of the things that I've said
to my audience repeatedly is,
first off I should tell
you you'll appreciate this,
I voted for Gary Johnson.
I'm here in California
and I had the luxury of,
doing a third-party situation
which obviously certain people,
depending on where you live,
you didn't have the luxury of doing that.
But I wanted to make a vote for liberty
more than anything else.
But one of the reasons that I've become
more okay with Trump over
the last couple of years
is that the guy that I
respect most in the Senate,
you, has become one of his big allies.
And my feeling was well, if Rand Paul,
who I aligned with on so
much of the liberty stuff,
sees something in him
that he can work with,
then I view that as a net good.
Can you talk about, a little bit about
your relationship
personally, but also just
what do you think his actual
governing principles are?
Cause it's hard to say they're
traditionally conservative
or Republican or whatever else.
- He doesn't come from a
steeped, developed nation
of possibly, of Libertarianism.
However, when you talk to him about war
and he talks about the Iraq War,
he gets it more than any other Republican,
obviously other than my
dad or myself or Mike Lee.
He get it, and he says the
Iraq War was a mistake.
He was unafraid to criticize the Bush's
for making what he said was the biggest
foreign policy blunder
of the last few decades.
And he's right about that.
And if you talk to him
he'll tell you consistently,
he wants to bring the troops
home from Afghanistan,
he wants to end the war.
But here's the problem
is it is a tug of war.
I tried to influence and,
really I don't think
you can change people,
I think you can tug at their instincts
and try to bring them in a direction
they may already believe in,
and I think he already
does believe those things.
The hard part is he's
been surrounded often,
and many of his appointees
have been people
with opposite opinion of ours,
but also opposite opinion
of the presidents.
John Bolton was a disaster.
John Bolton sort of is the
antithesis of Libertarianism.
He's a big spending hawk
and never met a war he didn't like.
And never met a civil
liberty he wouldn't trample.
And yet, he got picked
and was on the inside,
but he was there everyday,
and I'm talking to the
President once a week,
so imagine disadvantage.
Lindsey Graham's on
that same side as well,
so we, he's pushing one way,
we're pushing the other.
But I can tell you in private,
when it's the President,
I, and Lindsey Graham,
he'll often rebuke if
not always rebuke Graham
for being for so much war,
being for perpetual war.
All that being said,
Libertarians, limited government people,
people who want less war
who are conservatives,
all get frustrated.
It's like, well how can we have about
the same amount of troops?
We got more troops in Saudi Arabia.
But also look at it this way.
It's always a balance of
how, of what it could be.
So for example,
the conflict with Iran,
had you had Lindsey Graham
as president during that,
we would have blown up Iran.
We would've had a whole war.
We may well of had regime
change and people say,
oh that'd be good.
Well, but it could be chaos,
and it could be another
10 or 15 years of chaos
in that region.
So,
I think the President does show restrain.
They shot a drone down.
Of course they said they didn't,
but I mean, all evidence pointed
(Dave laughs)
towards them shooting
a drone down.
And the President showed restraint.
He said, "Well nobody was killed
"and they were encouraging me,
"everybody wanted me to attack Iran.
"It was gonna be limited
but we're gonna kill,
"I don't know, 150 or 450 or something."
He just said,
"We're just not gonna do it."
And I think there's a great,
there's statesmanship in restraint and
I think he shows that.
I think his instincts are good on war
and I think Libertarians who decide,
I wanna affect the election,
not mine as a battleground state.
I think we should look
for things like that.
Is he a perfect Libertarian?
No, he doesn't seem to be
too concerned with debt
or really decides in
the scope of government
as much as many of us would wish,
but on war he has some
instincts towards less war,
less intervention,
on money we spend overseas
and international agencies
and all this stuff that we
give up our sovereignty,
And these international agencies, blast us
and harangue us and
tell us how evil we are
while cashing our checks
that pays for all of their salaries.
He's very good on understanding that
and thinking that other people
need to pay their fair share.
And so, there's a lot to be
said that's good and then,
it is always, we're all,
I tell people, if you want
the perfect candidate,
run for office yourself.
(Dave laughs)
Otherwise you're always picking
and choosing and trying to find the best
that you can possibly find.
- Yeah.
So, all right.
Let's shift a little bit
towards corona and stimulus
and just what's happening broadly.
I'm finding right now
that there actually is
a really nice moment for
liberty-minded people
because one of the things that
we're suddenly talking about
in America that we never talk about or,
when I go to Libertarian
conferences they talk about it
but nobody else talks about it,
is states' rights.
That is actually something being discussed
at a national level right now.
I think people are realizing
they should be able to
protect their family,
so talking about the Second Amendment.
I think people are realizing that
maybe they don't wanna be
in giant cities anymore,
and I sense we're gonna have some really
interesting population things changing.
Do you sense that because of coronavirus,
that the Liberty Movement
and people realizing that
your congressman and your senator
are way more important,
or should be way more important
to your life than your President,
are you hoping that
something might crack here?
I mean, I'm even seeing lefties say
we should lower taxes
on people now because
they need more money in their pocket.
- Well, you're optimistic and I'm glad
you're optimistic on it.
I would say this.
I would say one of the lessons
we can and should learn from
the way government responds to this virus,
is that one size doesn't fit all.
And that would go along with federalism.
And that would go along with really,
you should try to devolve to
the smallest governmental unit
and really be on that.
The Ninth Amendment says,
the rights not listed
are not to be disparaged
but they're to be left to
the states and the people.
It's important it's not
just state governments cause
state governments can
be tyrannical as well.
But really, and the people.
The problem we have is even
though we have devolved,
most of Trump's pronouncements,
even the ones that have been restrictive,
have been guidelines without penalties.
Most of the penalties, and
most of the punishment,
most of the absolute
shutdown of the economy,
came from governors.
So even though it did devolve the states,
the states were, and my state included.
My governor is a just,
I call him DWP.
Drunk with power.
The guys intoxicated with his own power.
But here's what happened.
In our state, the legislature,
who knows when, years ago,
passed an emergency action bill
and said the governor gets
it during an emergency.
And I think he even gets
to declare the emergency.
I mean, there's no check and balance.
Our legislator can't call
themselves back in session.
We have a majority Republican legislature.
They have no say.
The governor has become
essentially the sole,
and unique, and all powerful person
that dictates everything
about the economy.
He closed everything down,
and he's still saying things like,
well, we're not gonna
have child care open up
until we get a vaccine.
It's like, really?
So working parents aren't going back,
what if we never get a vaccine?
He banned church, he
banned interstate travel.
The court struck him down on both of those
but he keeps on going and he acts as if
he's really out there to
try to help save the people.
We've had a little bit over 300 deaths,
and that's sad if it was
somebody in your family,
but that really, the number
of deaths in Kentucky
closely mirror the flu from before.
I'm not saying this is
the traditional flu,
but I am saying in certain states,
the outcome has not
been worse than the flu.
The other thing about one-size-fit-all
that we need to recognize is,
young people have almost
a zero mortality to this.
Zero to 18, almost zero.
Less than the flu, they
don't wanna hear it.
But zero to 18 deaths among
children is less than the flu.
Flue is more deadly.
Now if it goes up, it's the opposite.
When you get to 70 and 80,
particularly if you're 80 and above
and you are in a nursing home,
it might be 20 or 25% mortality
which is 50 times worse than the flu.
So, but that means maybe we
should have a different strategy
for the kids than we have for the elderly.
And maybe we didn't have
to close the economy down.
Maybe we could've done what Sweden did
and not close the schools down.
We still have knuckleheads
like my governor
who wanted to keep schools
closed in the fall.
It's a disaster, the
economy can't function.
Many people work with
their kids in school,
that's where their kids go,
it's a form of a place for your kids to go
while the parents work.
And so we've gotta open the schools but,
that's the biggest thing we have to do
and you're right,
some of it devolves back to
states and we should want more.
But really we shouldn't stop
the devolution of power with the governor,
we gotta go to the cities mayors,
and really ultimately,
if you own your business,
it's your business and,
you're gonna have to
respond to public pressure.
I don't have to tell you what to do.
But if you own a restaurant and you say
I'm gonna do nothing,
you're gonna get some people like me
who have already had it,
would love to come to your restaurant.
But a lot of people are gonna be worried
you're gonna have to do other things.
You may have to have a
senior citizens section,
you may have to have some spacing.
But if the government mandates it,
they'll be idiots.
They'll tell everybody
to sit six feet apart,
and if I've got five kids,
I don't need to socially
distance from my kids.
We should all sit at one
table on top of each other.
You know?
But if the government mandates it,
they're gonna do ridiculous things.
Businesses will figure this out.
Churches will figure this out.
If your mother's 85 years old
and she lives in a small town
and 20 people go to her church,
and they'll space out in the church
and she wants to go,
by golly let her go.
But if your mother's 85 years old
and she goes to a mega
church with 2,000 people
crammed into the pews,
I wouldn't mandate that she not go
but if she were my mother
I would tell her not to go.
I mean so,
we're not stupid.
We should let people
make decisions on risk.
- Yeah, so you mentioned knuckleheads
and I'm here in California
as you may know,
so I've got Gavin Newsom as my governor
and I've got Eric Garcetti
as my mayor here in L.A.
These are big governments progressives.
So I'm gonna ask you for a
little life advice right now.
For the first time
since I moved to LA,
I love it here, it's
85 and sunny every day,
my life has thrived,
I've got a great small business,
I'm in my garage right now Senator,
it's pretty sweet.
But I am honestly thinking about leaving
because I don't trust that these people
will make the right decisions.
And I wonder, just generally,
what's your philosophy on,
cause I think a lot of people
are seeing this right now.
If they live in a state
that their officials' ideas are
totally incongruent with their beliefs,
do you generally believe
in stay and fight,
or would you say,
no you can get on over to Kentucky,
get on over to Florida,
get on over to Texas,
and go where maybe your
ideas are more in line?
Cause I think this is like
the most unspoken thing
in America right now.
- Well my family, lives in Texas
and I grew up in Texas
and I'll tell you what they
tell me about Californians.
You can come,
(Dave laughs)
you can bring your family,
- [Dave] I know.
- you can participate
in the economy in Texas,
but leave all those stupid political ideas
of the majority in
California, in California.
So that's not how (mumbles)
- [Dave] I know.
- but they worry,
so many Californians come,
complain about high taxes,
and then they come and they
vote for high taxes in Texas.
But Texas is kicking butt.
So is Nevada.
I mean, all the states that
have low or no income tax.
Look at the professional
golfers like Nicholson.
Remember they gave him such a hard time,
and then I think he did quietly leave.
He says, oh I'm not leaving,
and then you finally get him.
You're a fool if you're making high,
I mean, I know California is beautiful,
but they take all your income.
And they're gonna probably keep
you in your garage forever.
Your beards gonna turn,
it already is turning gray,
but I mean,
it could be (mumbles)
- [Dave] There's a little
gray in there.
and they let you out.
- Yeah, all right.
So, I think you're
telling me to get going.
I've got a lot of invites.
I'm trying to get Ted
Cruz to officially give me
some sort of package to get me there
so we'll see what happens.
- (mumbles) California it is so beautiful,
the coast and the
mountains and all of that,
it's just an amazing state.
So I love going out there and it's like,
except for your legislature
and the craziness you've got,
you have so many problems.
I don't even know how you exist.
In fact, you're a good example of how
resilient Capitalism is
despite having a bunch of,
the best word is knuckleheads, socialists,
government planners running your cities.
And yet somehow,
California still has so much going on
with the great climate for agriculture,
the great coastline for tourism.
So, we'll see but I think
there's a chronic exodus
from New York, California.
I'll give you an example
of what Rick Scott
told us the other day.
The former governor of
Florida now a senator.
He said,
"Florida has 3 million more
people than New York State,
"but has one half the state budget.
"This is another reason
not to send these people
"more bailout money because
they'll just waste it
"and we'll just reward bad behavior."
They also will never open the economy
if we pass this Democratic latest one
in addition to all the other bailouts,
you think they're more or less
likely to open their economy
if we give them money.
Though only reason these
people will open their economy
is when they run out of
other peoples' money.
And so, that's coming.
Their state treasuries are bare,
and they're gonna have
to eventually open up
even though they love controlling you
and telling you what to do,
they're gonna finally
become frightened when
there's no money to even
pay their own salaries.
- Yeah, all right Senator I
know you're crunched for time,
so I just have one more for you.
Can you just lay out sort of
the broad sort of Libertarian approach
when it comes to helping
people that need help most,
and stimulus packages and everything else,
this is where I see Libertarians
get hit all the time
and don't necessarily have a good comeback
when we see 30 million people unemployed
and we don't have the money
to bail everything out,
yet we always do it and
get further into debt
and you're basically the
only guy in the senate
talking about it.
What is the proper, or better than proper,
what is the responsible
approach to helping people
when we're telling them
that they can't work,
yet also knowing that we
don't even have the money
in the first place? (claps hand)
- I think the most
humanitarian economic
system is capitalism.
It creates enormous amounts of wealth,
and that's how you can help
those who can't help themselves,
is by having great and enormous
amounts of wealth created.
Socialism doesn't work.
I mean, if you think you're
gonna be a humanitarian,
elect Chavez.
Oh, that's right, you
already have in California.
But, I mean,
(Dave laughs)
We thing, we really think
- Yeah.
Don't rub it in.
- It's not gonna work.
Socialism doesn't work.
Capitalism is humanitarian.
And then the only other
thing to remember is that,
don't let people guilt you into anything.
Look, I feel an obligation
to my fellow man,
and most people do.
I feel an obligation.
I wanna live in a community
where there are not people in the streets,
hungry and begging.
I want people to be taken care of.
My wife and I participate in
several different charities
in our community.
We try to help raise money for them,
and we want there to be a place
where people with addiction,
for people getting out of prison
and trying to get a skill,
all those things are,
we actually want them for a selfish reason
cause we wanna live in a community.
John Allison is good at
describing this and saying,
he's been because he wants
to live in a community
where there aren't poor people everywhere
that are begging and on the streets.
He wants a community where
there is charity that takes care of them,
and we shouldn't be embarrassed to that,
that there's a selfish
reason to give charity.
Sort if an I'm radian sort of,
self interest in altruism actually.
But the other thing is that
we should remember that
there's a difference between
an obligation and a right.
So I have an obligation
to help my fellow man
because of my religious and moral beliefs.
But you don't have a
right to a penny from me.
And,
Bernie Sanders does not
have a right to conscript me
and make me give my services to somebody
who doesn't
have any money.
As a physician I do give my services.
But we just can't,
once we give in and say,
oh they have a right to our services,
then we're all slaves
and we shouldn't do it.
And I've had this fight
with Bernie before.
And it's a good YouTube clip of
he and I going back
and forth in committee.
But we shouldn't give in on these things.
We gotta keep fighting.
Even though we don't always win.
I think there's a much
broader audience out there
than there is in Washington.
We just gotta replace a few people.
If you'll help me replace a few people,
it'll be a lot better.
- I'm with you man.
Well, I really appreciate it.
And I wish we had more time but I know
you've got actual work to do.
So, get to fixing the whole system
and I hope we can do this
in person at some point.
- All right, thanks Dave.
- If you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful
conversation about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out out politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.